Es gibt, keine behandlung und keinen impfstoff
Und kein medikament gegen den erreger. Und nizza gehört mit 40 bis 75 prozent rate zu den tödlichsten viren der welt
1998 trat das virus zum ersten mal in malaysia auf inzwischen ist es bis nach indien gelangt wo es bereits
Zehn menschen umgebracht hat die weltgesundheitsorganisation
Vero ist alarmiert und hat vor dem erreger gewarnt ist. So eine weltweite epidemie
Eine pandemie alles über den erreger und die gefahr die jetzt von. Ihm ausgeht bei klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Das ist mal wieder vielen dank an meine follower bei den messestandort oder auf unserem neuen desktop server gehen
So viele themenvorschläge, ein absolut irre tausend dank ja was hat 98 trat das ehepaar virus zum ersten
mal lauf in malaysia
Und das hatte dort absolut extreme folgen damals wurde das virus über schweine verbreitet und die arbeiter und arbeiterinnen in schlachthäusern
Steckten sich offenbar an erkrankten schweinen an die behörden wussten sich nur mit einem zu helfen
Eine million schweine das waren die hälfte aller schweine im land wurden getötet und unter strengen auflagen
Vernichtet so dass sich niemand anstecken konnte es gibt nämlich absolut nichts was gegen die. Solche hilft. Keine impfung kein medikament
Keine, behandlung 40 bis 75 prozent der infizierten sterben einfach den
Ersten toten gab es in indien vor zwei wochen er ging von einem toten flug
Und aus der in einem brunnen gefunden wurde über die
Ansteckungswege weiß, er noch nicht so viel in indien vermutet man die infizierung über die
Ausscheidungen der flughunde sie fressen früchte an und hinterlassen code werden
Diese früchte jetzt gegessen oder zusetzten verarbeitet geraten die viren in den menschlichen körper
Deshalb wird jetzt vor dem verzehr von angefressenen früchten, und säften gewarnt aber es scheint
Sich jetzt wie bei ebola auch die ansteckung von mensch. Zu mensch, zu entwickeln in indien sind jetzt pflegerinnen
und pfleger erkrankt hier könnte die ansteckung über
Tröpfcheninfektion stattgefunden haben, 100 menschen sind inzwischen infiziert
der erreger, führt sohn symptomen wie bei einer, grippe, hohes fieber muskelschmerzen
Kopfschmerzen halsschmerzen und erbrechen ist der krankheitsverlauf tödlich. Kommen lungenentzündung
Und einer ebene tödliche hautentzündung dazu die, whu die weltgesundheitsorganisation warnt jetzt eindringlich vor dem erreger
Und fordert die rasche erforschung sie schätzt die gefahr für den ausbruch einer pandemie
also, einer weltweiten epidemie als hoch ein wenn, er kein video zum nizza virus
Und zu weiteren verlauf und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp untereinander messengern den
link gibt es jetzt hier, und nur dann verpasst
Ihr ein video denn die abo box auf youtube die ist ja immer ziemlich lückenhaft. Und über die messenger erfahrt
Ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich garantiert und dann bekommt, er auch den link zum diskurs server
Wo ich im moment mich täglich herumtreiber einfach hier draufklicken. Und am besten
Auch meinen schwesterkanal klicks, um, social and media abonnieren da erfahrt. Ihr das neueste aus der welt der social media aber nicht die
Glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken ebola ausbruch im kongo gerät außer. Kontrolle
bis dann
bleibt dran